don't spend money till you're making it
it's so easy to spend money this is the
thing when I was in Venture Capital
raising money for
companies everybody just showed how
they're going to spend money but not how
they're going to make it right it's so
easy to think about if I only had
$10,000 $50,000 $100,000 whatever you
can go buy all this stuff stop thinking
about the money you don't have right
instead you think about what you can do
with what you do have what can you use
you're a genius you're resourceful
you've got ideas how do you use that
creativity instead of thinking the
biggest problem is money the problem is
not money the problem is you're not
resourceful enough go off and solve that
problem